so we have a nice little equation here
dealing with rational expressions and i
encourage you to pause the video and see
if you can figure out what values of x
satisfy this equation
all right let's work through this
together
so
the first thing i'd like to do is just
see if i can simplify this at all and
maybe by finding some common factors
between numerators and denominators or
common factors on either side of the
equal sign so let's factor all of these
all of the numerators and denominators
all the ones on the right hand side are
already done so this thing up here
i could rewrite this as let's see
what what's product is 21 what two
numbers when i take their product is 21
positive 21 so they're going to have the
same sign
and when i add them i get negative 10
well negative 7 and negative 3 so this
could be written as x minus 7 times x
minus 3.
this over here both are divisible by 3.
i could rewrite this as 3 times x minus
4 and these are already factored so the
one thing that jumps out at me is i have
x minus 4 in the denominator on the left
hand side and on the right hand side and
so if i were to multiply both sides by x
minus 4. so actually let me just
let me formally replace this
with that
and up here it's not so obvious that's
going to be valuable for me to keep this
factored form so i'm just going to keep
it in this yellow form in the in the
expanded out form so let me just scratch
that out for now because once i well
let's let me multiply by x minus 4. so
if we multiply both sides by x minus 4
and once again why am i doing this so i
get rid of the x minus 4 is in the
denominator
x minus 4
and then
x minus 4.
that
and that cancels that and that cancels
and then we're left with in the
numerator we're left with our x squared
minus 10 x
plus 21
and let's see divided by 3
divided by
3
is equal to x minus 5.
let's see now what we could do and
actually i could have done it in the
last step is i could multiply both sides
by 3
multiply both sides do that another
color just so it sticks out a little bit
more
so i can multiply both sides by 3.
so multiply both sides
by three
on the left hand side that and that
cancels and i'll just be left with
x squared minus 10 x
plus 21 and on and i don't have a
denominator anymore my denominator is
one so i don't need to write it is going
to be equal to three times let's
distribute distribute the three three
times x is three x
three times negative five is negative
fifteen and now i can get this in
standard quadratic form by getting all
of these terms onto the left-hand side
the best way to do that let's subtract
3x from the right but i can't just do it
from the right otherwise the equality
won't hold i have to do it from both
sides if i want the equality to hold and
i want to get rid of this negative 15 so
i can add 15 to both sides
so
let's do that
and what we are left with scroll down a
little bit so i have a little more space
what we are going to be left with
is
x squared
minus 13x
and then plus what is this plus 36
plus
36. don't do that right yeah plus 36
is
equal to
is equal to zero
all right now let's see we have this is
a quadratic in the standard form how can
we solve this
so first thing can we factor this
product of two numbers 36 if i add them
i get negative 13 they're both going to
be negative since they have to have the
same sign to get their product to be
positive
and let's see 9 and 4 seem to do the
trick
so or negative 9 and negative 4. so x
minus 4 times x minus 9 is equal to 0.
well that's going to happen if either
if either x minus 4 is equal to 0
or
x minus 9 is equal to 0.
we'll add 4 to both sides of this this
happens when x is equal to 4
add 9 to both sides of this this happens
when x is equal to 9. so we could say
that the solutions are x equals 4 or x
equals 9.
so x is equal to 4
or
x equals 9 but we need to be careful
because we have to remember in our
original expression x minus 4 was a
factor of both denominators and so if we
actually tried to test x minus 4 in the
original equation not one of these
intermediary steps in the original
equation i would end up dividing by zero
right over here and i try to end up
dividing by zero right over there as
well so the original equations if i try
to substitute 4 they don't make sense so
this is actually an extraneous solution
it's not going to be a solution to the
original equation the only solution is
x is equal to nine